when Josh dos was traded to the
Minnesota Vikings on Halloween and then
had a game this past Sunday he was
really in no position to be playing
quarterback in the game he barely knew
anyone's name he hadn't taken one single
rep with the offense in practice and he
never practiced any snaps from Garrett
Bradberry but then Vikings rookie QB
jiren hall went down from a concussion
in the first quarter and dos had to step
in the Vikings had to think fast and
learn faster do said Vikings head coach
Kevin oconnell was translating calls and
teaching him plays mid huddle as the
play clock was running dos said oconnell
would be in his ear telling him what he
would about to be looking at the winning
touchdown was a play DOS had never run
before but he recalled it from one of
okell's call sheets and he just made it
work winning the game for the Minnesota
Vikings